[Music]
- boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sock in
today we have the pleasure of sitting
down with Sam Oh
Maria hello it's a pleasure to be here
thank you for coming on today right I'm
so excited for this conversation it's
it's not often you get to talk about
society as a whole and where
civilization is going or might be going
so I'm back always very happy to sit
down and talk talk this through with
interesting people that's so crucial
when was the last time that you sat down
with someone to talk about what has been
good of our society what has been bad
about society where we can go in the
future and I just love having that
conversation and you should literally
study that conversation as a social
scientist ask someone that founded
Bismarck analysis you you are constantly
analyzing governments and institutions
for the purposes of private clients that
hire you to do so correct correct it's
it's very interesting where there's you
know a lack of a certain kind of
discussion in the public space we used
to have you know pretty live culture of
public intellectuals yes both in America
and the West at large there's much less
of this now it used to be the case that
you know public intellectuals would say
something and then newspapers would
report on it now newspapers say
something or you know maybe someone
tweets something and then intellectuals
comment on that without this sort of
like the election these conversations do
still happen in private people still
talk about this in great detail you
might they might ask themselves well
what is actually going on with the
federal government what is happening
with the government of China what is
happening with various economic sectors
what might be happening in our
scientific institutions our epistemic
institutions in general even the
newspapers themselves are things we
should like you know be analyzing
questioning figuring out the role that
they play in our society without these
things it's very it's very hard to have
public conversations worth having right
and then like if we have very good
friends we can meet our friends talk
about it but then the question is well
this knowledge if we're building it out
how do we translate that into something
that benefits society something that
changes you know changes the course of
history yeah and you mentioned a key
word there epistemic or esta mala G the
study of what's justified truth or
what's just belief into society I love
that word and I've been you know talking
about that word for such a long time now
and I've been trying to get other people
to care more about that word because
that's basically what we're doing with
our analysis of the world all the time
what is truth what is just justified
belief and then how can we bring these
bodies of knowledge together into these
shared methodologies and practices to
build a better future moving forward so
you focus on history you focus on
analyzing it taking away some of the
good the bad there's so much more to
unpack here but yeah where where were
you born how did this all start were
reborn okay well I was born in Slovenia
a little before the collapse of what was
once its own World Order right the
communist bloc used to exist it used to
be a third of the planet pursuing a
shared vision of the future and had a
story of how it was the best Society
ever and that everything was going to go
great well you know I was born in
Yugoslavia right 1988 so this is like
you know when I'm three years old I'm
there with my parents and you know
they're taking me to an air-raid shelter
and they don't want to scare the little
303 year old boy who's asking what's
happening
leaving our home in the middle of the
night yeah so they just say you know oh
no the firemen are just having a drill
and then I'm like stupid fireman like
the three year old kid just really
didn't like firemen that evening what
this angered I think it illustrates is
that as such our views of what's a
stable society and what's a fragile
society yeah can be very complacent yeah
right loose lobby approved you know the
country was born proved to be fragile
you know then I grew up in the 1990s and
an independent Slovenia
there's trying very hard to you know
transition to the Western model I think
it was moderately successful at this
we're you know relatively prosperous
country I grew up watching American
movies and that was a big cultural
contrast a big generational contrast
yeah like imagine if in the 1990s you
know Selena is flooded with American TV
shows so you might watch Fresh Prince of
bel-air and it's on air at the same time
as I Love Lucy is on her like that's a
major cultural shift and it's somehow
like 50 years of American pop culture
her packed into the you know these
decent discount small TV stations
transmitting this stuff and you know for
the older generation they were quite
cynical right you know when we were
growing up I you know remember talking
to my parents and I'm sort of like well
you know when's the first time you know
how do you feel the first time you voted
now do we have democracy after 1991 and
my dad said well you know obviously we'd
voted for a long time before it was just
a question of who gets to pick the
candidates and this is this you know for
me it was very memorable because it
pointed out how you know the form the
form of a system or society might be
very different from the substance that
exists in them the form of the society
might be different front of substance
that exists in it right right so even
though on the outside we have a
democracy in the u.s. on the inside
there might be a lot of polarization and
gridlock mm-hmm like I think it would be
very difficult to argue that the
government is responsive to either the
needs or the desires of the people
as an interesting question well you know
how how does one figure out which of
these many contradictory desires are the
ones that you know can be empowered for
the good of everyone which are perhaps
the ones that should not be empowered
which are the passions there in fact too
much and in fact might be too rash for
bad decisions
so how when did you move to the US I
really think us two years ago three
years ago yes yes English is fantastic
all of you you know we're learning a lot
from those TV I'm afraid some more books
books good
I still get in trouble for for
mispronouncing words because there's
some words
I only ever read never heard oh yeah
cool right what looks like what's an
example oh man I I can only give
examples that I've since corrected yeah
for example I was the word was a word
[Music]
this is gonna be funny I actually
mispronounced Tribble it I still don't
know how to mispronounce the word way to
prance the worst rabble it yeah yeah
what is Shibboleth oh I still not sure
if I'm pronouncing it right but Sybil it
was it's a it's a small biblical
reference it's a word that means that
you know but the way you pronounce a
word people can tell where you're from
oh cool right right so loosely these two
warring tribes and colloquialism can be
I think a similar it's similar it's not
quite the same this marker this marker
of the longing right it's almost like is
kind of status marker yeah right we're
colloquialism is like something vocal or
jargon is something that's in a
professional domain okay yeah yeah like
I should beware yeah I mean some who was
helped I you know I travel around Europe
and Europe you know English is now the
lingua franca like the EU and the
European Union and European project like
if you go talk to people they'll talk to
you in English Wow because there are
many small ethnicities you know what's
the one language you know both the poles
and the Spanish yeah and you know the
French will agree well okay maybe the
French will refuse to speak English just
on principle yeah yeah you you learn a
lot just by traveling around but then
China we have Mandarin we have Chloe
and we have Arabic there's some major
languages languages in the world yeah
okay so you moved to the US three years
ago you moved to the Bay Area yes
okay cool how did you pick the Bay Area
because this is kind of the hub to be
that's true that's true I actually
wasn't I wasn't attracted by the tech
industry directly maybe indirectly what
I had done for many years was reached
out to people to academics interesting
thinkers people who I thought were doing
interesting things that might be
relevant to my core research micro
research was again trying to figure out
you know how does civilization is a
whole work had a society as a whole work
after a while I realized wait I'm
corresponding and creating mailing lists
and skyping with people in the
english-speaking world almost always
like 90 percent of my contacts they were
also fuse in and Russia or some other
verses but these were english-speaking
people and all of those half of them
were in the Bay Area so I cool to myself
that you know who the bay area is as
interesting as the rest of the
Anglosphere put together uh-huh
hmm so after having assembled this like
large list and large list of friends you
know I was well I should try to move
there I should go there you know either
I'll go study something or I'll go work
somewhere you know but there's a reason
why you were talking to so many people
that were from this area sure there's a
lot of diverse intellect that is
concentrated in this area and that's why
I love living here I think the network
effect is only gonna keep growing here
over time we'll see when location
agnosticism becomes a big thing with
maybe the indistinguishable virtual
realities that maybe a little matter as
much but for now it will take a while
they'll take a while the human presence
is something special they don't think
it's just audio-visual it's something
about the flow of the interaction and
everything exactly replaceable the
energy of your heart and my heart my
brain writing in the same place okay so
you let's unpack civilizational analysis
because where does one even start when
it says okay I'm gonna analyze Society
there's a lot of different places so
start yes infinite but what is a really
good way to start if not the best way to
start unpacking civilization well to
reference back a point earlier I think
you have to start if you're pursuing
knowledge both with some humility but
also some courage the humility has to
come from you don't assume you already
know how things work
yeah and it's includes you don't
necessarily have to you can't actually
by default simply trust what you've been
taught or told Bryce just as perhaps
like you know Yugoslavian society wasn't
telling the whole truth about itself
us or our society might not be telling
that the full truth itself this is not
like a point against either I think all
societies have had have struggled to
correctly interpret themselves so we
don't even need to you know consider
that there's you know some sort of like
you know elite versus masses distinction
and a need for deception it could just
be all-round confusion
regardless very good point regardless of
what's actually happening in that regard
yeah you need to take to yourself the
privilege to think for yourself first
and maybe that's one of the reasons that
you know the bit is so attractive
because people here are very open to you
know first principles reasoning
rethinking entire industries rethinking
entire philosophies yes you know
refactoring them reorienting them
methodologically then if you come from a
start-up from a place of skepticism you
then can go into data-driven social
science in fact think there's many
positive things to be done there my you
know formal educational background was
in physics so I started with a very you
know this sort of a quantitative
approach as very excited about big data
and so on I still think that you know if
you are an intelligent engineer at
Facebook you might just have the best
social science knowledge in the world
yeah one question is again how do you
publish it right the earlier yeah where
simply because if knowledge exists in
these like small private branches
doesn't mean the rest of society
necessarily benefits or that in your
non-work urs book you get to learn what
amounts to a trade secret right yes
but I was a little bit disillusioned
with some of the
the larger approaches like I can give
another very interesting example you
know in 1937 there was a census of the
Soviet Union a census wouldn't they just
go out and count the people the expected
population of the Soviet Union was 180
million the result was 170 million the
reason was because they wanted to
present themselves as a successful
Society at all levels so wasn't that the
leadership of the Soviet Union was
trying to deceive the world the
leadership itself had been deceived
because of the way the bureaucratic
incentives worked each step of the way
only good news was recorded each step up
the chain of command of the hierarchy
and you know they arrested all the
statisticians that compiled the result
of 170 million people and the new
statisticians came to the same result
and so they arrested those as well and
then they declared that you know the
census was sabotage but obviously it
wasn't sabotage what it happened was
they had built a massive information
gathering apparatus and did not align
the incentive of this massive
information gathering apparatus even for
the leadership let alone for the
population of the Soviet Union as a
whole so if you are in the Soviet Union
in 1940 you couldn't trust population
numbers and population numbers are
actually one of the things governments
are very very good at their doing
governments are well incentivized to you
know count people accurately both for
purposes of Taxation and you know it
because this is the 20th century this is
the 1930s conscription like the Soviet
government definitely wanted to know how
many soldiers it could enlist right now
and if we were skeptical of something
simple like a population number how can
you think something like a GDP figure is
fully accurate right there oh yeah yeah
there are lots of people you know they
think it was 2006 2007 again you know
Slovenia was transitioning to the
Western system and they changed how they
counted GDP they added what's called the
gray economy or the semi-legal economy
to the GDP numbers what is the
semi-legal economy uh it's basically
stuff that's not regulated but is legal
sort of something that falls short of
full paperwork compliance and that makes
sense you've heard
term like black economy black market oh
they write great racist something that's
technically violating law but it's it's
not because people are doing something
bad is because they're you know not
they're engaged in like you know
decriminalize activity or just very bad
at paperwork and are not reporting it
and they're trying to boost their GDP
for a multitude of reasons one of them
potentially being that they want other
nations to view them as a good trade
partner correct correct so the Slovenian
government you know early 2000s just
touted these numbers as economic growth
at least domestically yes we have all
basis life to the way of a place like
China that has been touting some GDP
increases that people are saying are not
actually real due to them building the
roads and these ghost cities to places
that people don't even live at times and
things like this that is very very
interesting but then again they're
building a world-class Convention Center
in a couple months and Tianjin you know
so there's a very interesting sort of so
so you I love your first principles
analysis so you mentioned one of the
first things being seeking knowledge yes
and then as you seek knowledge humility
is crucial scepticism is crucial
humility in saying I know nothing I'm
going to openly say that I know maybe
that gravity exists maybe that I
shouldn't kill other people that these
are things that I should move forward
with and then the further analysis is
that I'm going to be skeptical of all of
this information that comes my way I'm
going to think about it in a in a way
that questions it right away and then I
run an analysis ten times again of this
information to see if it's true or not
I'd go and take samples of other
people's thoughts if it's true or not
and then that that sort of builds you up
this sort of first principles
understanding
well first principles understanding
already presupposes you have some sort
of paradigm you're operating in so at
first you have to figure out well okay
as I said who you trust secondly pick
methods based on these methods try to
you know propose what your first
understanding is of how things are you
never come with you know you come with /
something you come with assumptions you
might as well bring those to light and
see what's happening one of my favorite
analogies here is the one of geology
you know people tend to agree geology as
a science but in geology there's no such
thing as a controlled experiment in
geology we only have this you know one
planet you know okay
let's leave what NASA or Elon might be
doing analyzing the geology of other
planets regardless we're here with this
earth is this you know multi billion
year process when we have a theory on
where certain kinds of rocks should be
what we do is we put the theory up and
then we go dig for those rocks and then
we find those rocks those rocks were
already there we didn't set up a new
experiment we're searching for
essentially natural experiments than the
world we're searching they're like
examples of what's happening and if our
predictions were correct this is
evidence for the theory if however we
dig and we find different kinds of rock
or like don't find oil or don't find the
minerals we thought were there well then
maybe we need to revise what we think
has been happening with the earth
geology
I feel society is very similar you don't
actually get to run a society-wide
experiment ever even if you say be kind
or just kind of become a society-wide
experiment
well maybe money has their is their
control there's no control there's no
control yeah that's the point there's no
control and you know I I don't know if
there may be somewhere there's a hidden
brilliant scientist that set up the
experiment to prove or disprove a
certain theory but you know I I don't
think I don't think that's actually
because some people say that if you
raise children to not communicate using
language from a young age then that
severely impairs them from their future
and other people will argue that if you
don't teach language there might be some
other creative way that they might
communicate through their eyes or
eyebrows or through
their senses and all this kind of stuff
Iike the baby advanced the human race
and other senses and it could be very
interesting to not be vocalizing and
listening through these senses and then
this the the control is very interesting
if there was a control on these
processes if we were really testing in a
controlled setting what money does to
society what language just a society I
think we would learn so much and we're
missing out on on our analysis of how
society works I think I think part of it
almost goes you know slightly different
direction there's no control but there
do exist past societies that maybe did
things differently and we also have
possibilities for the future things we
can try to build within our society on
say a smaller scale to test various
principles scaling problems are of
course very interesting you know anyone
I have some libertarian friends I'm not
a libertarian myself some of them run
silly experiments like try to use market
mechanisms to figure out who should wash
the dishes
if you imagine parents with their kids
having a bidding system in a sense this
is a very voluntary uh but in another
sense they're totally missing the point
this their own theory says that this
sort of price mechanism type thing only
works where there are many many people
who can provide these services in your
apartment no one's gonna be bidding on
who should clean the dishes except well
you may be a wife or a partner or your
children it's no there's no sense to
organize it like a market yeah so this
the key scaling thing is regardless of
what one thinks about markets there are
perhaps some things that only work at a
very large scale and do not work at a
very small scale
you can't do real small scale government
for example you can't even do certain
kinds of small-scale economic
experiments because economies of scale
are a thing certain kinds of
organization only become you know viable
at the larger scale what if there was a
bid out for somebody from the outside
world to come and do the dishes for five
bucks oh then you're just interfacing
with the outside world and wider
then you figure it out probably a good
app I'm sure it would have a snappy name
on your phone is like who will come
clean my dishes two handsome ones we
swipe right and then they come and clean
your dishes for you know five or six or
seven dollars and it probably over to
your place to it's a partnership with
you here I'm joking but the thing is
that's already interfacing with a much
bigger system yeah versus the closed
four-person fail right correct and we're
looking at society its society as a
whole closed system not completely
we are partially outsourcing things to
you know the earth's ecosystem right we
don't produce our own oxygen right we do
de facto take care of most of our own
drinking water because the key problem
with drinking water is usually
sanitation yeah it's not like literal
physical lack of water yeah it's like
misuse of water resources
you know California's famous for its
droughts and so on but you know we're
farm subsidies lower more of the water
could be used by the population itself
rather than for this large agricultural
project projects right one side effect
is we enjoy cheap almonds here they're
very delicious but those farms use up a
lot of the water yes does it make sense
to grow almonds in the desert in
California not really but the subsidies
are there and structurally it's very
difficult to get rid of them yeah yeah
stuff like this is so fascinating so
there's this we don't we don't produce
oxygen we are in an ecological symbiosis
with the earth and then we we do
sanitize the water we produce humans
live in deserts where it's very
difficult to grow food and to have water
and to air conditioned buildings and all
this kind of stuff we have so much more
to unpack it's so difficult to actually
figure out how to actually parse this I
think where we started
let's build from there so we we started
with the thirst for knowledge and then
leveraging things like humility and and
critical thinking free thinking
historical context let's let's yeah
unpack unpack that more when you go into
history
where do you how do you analyze history
for it yeah my best advice here would be
and my best principle would be that
events are very ambiguous it's very easy
to have multiple plausible reasons why a
particular event did or did not happen
so events based history we're sort of
taught in high school you know when you
have a date and then this data this
happened and fifty years later this
happened and hundred years later this
happened seems strictly less useful than
going for a case study approach where
you holistically look either at a
particular individual or an institution
given the track record of that
individual institution it becomes very
clear over time how it is it does what
it does right there's no ambiguity of
well who exactly caused this market
crash if we exactly caused this war it's
more like this military works this way
across five Wars or so so it's an
example maybe would be the way that you
could either put a couple dates on when
the genocide of the Jews happened if you
put those dates on it or you can talk
about how the military force of Germany
rallied for that period of time how they
operated how they worked how they talked
and what actually happened over those
years with plucking people moving them
to concentration camp like how they kill
them so that sort of a story versus just
dates correct I mean that kind of story
it's like it's a question of what you're
analyzing how you're analyzing it you
know your reference a very you know a
tragic moment in human history I think
it's also possible to reference a
positive positive one definitely the
polio eradication programs must benefit
all samples
thank you Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation that's actually a few decades
earlier but the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation are doing very good things
with malaria
sorry polio is a both recently the
smallpox one was the one I want to try
oh that's a few decades earlier you're
correct
you're correct I misspoke
bureaucracies right you you have what
amounts to a machine made of people
people in a bureaucracy follow
particular rules if you want to analyze
that kind of institution you're going to
look at the documents and the paper
trails people make there so if you're
looking holistically at an institution
ideally you get to see some of their
documents this might be their you know
official publications these might be
their correspondences these might be
internal memos this might be forms a
form is something people produced to
satisfy rules within a bureaucracy right
so there's someone that works at one
level rights report to their boss the
boss doesn't necessarily read the report
the report has to be a certain shape so
when you get a document into your hands
you have to first decide is this written
for rules or is this written for people
or czar in for free thought and all that
kind of stuff sure that happens that
happens as well but I'm talking here in
the context of analyzing an institution
I feel like we needed to talk about
which institutions we should analyze in
history like what would you say would be
the good institutions to go back and
look at are we talking like a US
government over over a period of time
and how it may be drafted up this
constitution and then how it amended
this Constitution and how society
flourished from that Constitution or how
it decayed in some ways that's it's a
very interesting case study definitely
the American Revolution and the
development of American governments what
didn't one of the big impacts on the
world so that would be if that would be
a good one to look at it would be it
would be difficult though it would be
difficult first off there are many
people who have already looked at it you
are going to come in with preconceived
notions of what's happening there is a
lot of emotional attachment and a lot of
also national pride up in a particular
interpretation of what happened so if
you can approach it with an unbiased
take if you can approach it with like a
slightly disinterest to take you can
learn a lot and it will be a very good
thing to study but there's some virtue
in studying well last known parts of
history maybe other societies and
civilizations one of my favorite takes
is like you know
in the West we know a lot about say the
collapse of Rome and the rise of
Christianity but what we don't
necessarily think about is what is
Confucius's period like yeah confucius
is coming in in the so-called warring
States period it's a very dark period
what was that for your fuss is about 3
to 400 BCE exactly yeah yeah so
convergence of verses Rome's about a
thousand the fall of Rome the Roman
Empire is like 5th century AD the idea
but it you know lasts many hundreds of
years obviously but the thing about
Confucius though is that he proposes you
know our societies in trouble these are
a thousand years away from one another
by the way of course just to put it on a
timeline because this is where if we're
looking at 2018 and we're looking at
like my 25 year old life and a lot of
our 25 year old lives we're looking at a
period of a grain of sand basically in
time right and then if you go back a
thousand years even almost 1500 years to
the fall of Rome rise of Christianity
that when you're looking at that that is
like fifteen hundred years ago then
you're trying to then you go back
another thousand years to Confucius and
so no no I'm just saying now look
forward 1,000 years from 2018 to 30:18
because we're trying to put this all on
a timeline because what is life gonna be
like in thirty eighteen how do we want
to lift move forward in that next
thousand years as well as as we look
back and try and analyze and take good
principles yeah looking at the longest
time scale is very useful long-term
thinking is actually something that has
very nice dividend with societies it's
also this sort of take that
it's the sort of take where if we're
always making decisions for the very
short-term all that we manage to do is
optimize this very small part of the
world like maybe we make something that
lasts for a few years maybe we you know
personally make a profit and live well
briefly but if there is no one
positioned in society to act for
long-term benefit or if there are no
institutions coordinating for long-term
benefit we're going to suffer you know
pretty serious consequences
now both China you know two and a half
thousand years ago as you say and the
room at Empire thousand five hundred
years ago were societies that where all
of the individuals were sort of you know
rational human beings trying to make
their way in the world trying to live
their lives but the some of their
efforts eventually did produce you know
led to serious trouble for them the
example of Confucius I was bringing up
as this person who decided to you know
study history study the functioning of
earlier Chinese civilization which he
thought worked well and then figure out
how to bring this into the present one
of the you know chief and virtues
Confucianism advocates as a Ren which
stands for humanity a kind of humanism
he proposed that you know a good society
has excellent people in it people that
flourish people that thrive yeah and
that the best way to achieve this is
well to have good relations between the
individuals yes but also to have a good
understanding of well okay how does how
do we correctly describe what's going on
what sort of rituals should govern our
interpersonal interaction or emotional
lives but also the abuse yes so he
looked at decided all scales starting
with the individual then with the
groupings family then with society as a
whole
those are really crucial levels they are
to may interact with each other they do
interact with each other and then also
if we're going back to this best
principle sort of analysis of what we're
trying to discuss here to to get a a
individual flourishing right and then to
get the family and a tribal flourishing
right and then to get the societal burek
Radek flourishing right these levels how
they engage with each other
I think inner management on the and the
individual levels really important yes
and then and then for this family or
more tribal is how can we you know
flourish together in that but also how
can we actualize ourselves and those
tribes to try and bring value to the
world and engage with other tribes and
on the society bureaucratic one it's so
difficult to actually figure that out
but I still think that putting in some
sort of some sort of key but key bits
like you know everybody should have
access to clean water or to oxygen to
breathe these basic physiological needs
so any so anyway it gets a little more
complicated when you get up there but
I'm glad that you brought that up and
how those Reap interplay with one
another and how you're bringing up
confucius and how he really said you
know as you bring that up how did you
identify that as something that was
being that was his essence how did you
how do you how does one find but you can
you can read what he wrote you can read
what you what he wrote and we preserved
those some of it some of it the Analects
of Confucius or of course one of the big
Chinese classics and you can also read
about his times and the sort of
individual states he was interacting
with I think Confucius is like a
wonderful example of someone that does
succeed in sharing knowledge with
society both in creating knowledge with
society and then having it propagate
into the future it was you know his
long-term dream that you know he'll get
the ear of one prince or another and
have the prince institute these reforms
which would encourage his kind of
meritocratic system of education where
people were you know read not just you
know the tax code but also poetry and
that was you know making that part of
the civil exam system make poetry part
of the civil exam system to encourage
like a more humane mindset where the
bureaucrat then realizes that no
actually do have decision-making power I
am a human being I should keep in mind
the humanity of everyone a interact with
while discharging these duties I might
have to
towards the state correctly like
harmonizing these elements was the core
of Confucius's philosophy and then when
you when you read his philosophy and his
actions and the context you realize his
actions are taken to the best of his
understanding appropriate for his
context absolutely what he does he says
okay this is a decaying society he'll
walk I know right he says this is a
decaying society people don't know
what's going on anymore these states are
constantly at war with each other
there's no peace people don't read
people don't read classics anymore and
he travels around China gathering
students a large group of students and
he goes around trying to petition
various governments look if you
Institute this not only will this be you
know good and virtuous and humane you
just have a more functional state and
it'll work out for you
now Confucius is less good at office
politics and just normal politics so it
never quite works out for him but one of
his students mensches who takes on his
philosophy does correctly does reach the
Han Dynasty and then the Han Dynasty
this is you know after the Qin Dynasty
implements a lot of these reforms and
ever since then Confucianism has been
one of these bedrocks of Chinese
civilization so so the golden the Golden
Age of like the second and third century
AD so this is a few hundred years later
substantially in everything they say
they reference back to this one teacher
wandering China collecting students and
then trying to reach people in positions
of power and trying to explain look to
my best of my understanding this is how
things work
isn't that what we're doing we're trying
to gravitate really fun and driven and
people that are trying to analyze
civilizations good things and we're
trying to drive them into a collective
that then goes and chats with people in
power and like hey we confront our
society better ways I'm so excited
because that is that is in essence what
these institutions that I think we're
gonna touch on in a little bit as well
and how we analyze them what good are
they bringing to the world are they may
be bringing some bad into the world
let's go that thousand years ahead now
to the in the future well or to
go to the Rome to the fall room in the
rise of Christianity what can we pluck
away from maybe that and then we'll go
to the okay very very interesting
question I think it's a it's an example
we all know well it's one that's worth
studying I would argue that the Roman
Empire has a key problem where it has
simultaneously over centralization an
endemic internal warfare I think usually
we have this intuition that if things
are decentralized then people fight and
if things are centralized and people
don't fight but actually in the Roman
Empire the key problem is that you know
every time when you know a Roman Emperor
dies all the legions in each of their
generals has a shot at being the Emperor
and the only thing sort of worth doing
for a general in the Roman Empire is to
try to be the Emperor of the Roman
Empire so all of them are competing for
the same prize at the center in Rome and
they keep marching their armies back
every time right these armies are costly
they're expensive right so they're also
over taxing the population this is
choking in many very serious ways you
know the economy of at least the Western
Roman Empire the eastern Roman Empire is
wealthier they're constantly relying on
more and more outside assistance well we
have this view of you know the barbarian
invasions it's a lot more nuanced than
that the Roman state needs soldiers so
it often invites Germanic tribes for a
fee you know here you guys can settle in
this land you have to provide these many
people to fight for us and over the
course of you know their history in the
last 200 years the Roman stage has fewer
and fewer of its own legions and more
and more Germanic warriors and then the
Germanic warriors are very good soldiers
they fight very well versus other
barbarians but at one point the Roman
state is completely hollowed out it's
this massive tax collection apparatus it
is run by people that are selected
through like dubious means right so it's
sort of like this kind of
war type dynamic and most of the
fighting troops it's not the state
itself that's producing the fighting
troops or the excellent people so it's a
very natural state we're in the fifth
century four seven 600 docker who's
who's a you know a romanized Germanic
barbarians not a barbarian at all he
speaks you know and writes good Latin
but he goes with a tribe and just
opposes the last Roman Emperor Emperor
so that's the end of the Roman state it
was relying more and more on an outside
institution there's functional tribes
that provided it with military power and
the tribes quite sensibly abolished what
just ended up being a pointless
institution right what happened for most
people with the fall of the Roman Empire
was nothing in particular for many
centuries life had been getting poorer
and poorer security had been less and
less and then is there a point in
continuing this thing not really
right so with the ring down it's not a
sudden collapse
it's a withering down a wearing down and
the few remaining functional
institutions at one point are like nope
we're gonna put aside this thing right
and you know the barbarians get a very
negative rap but you know in the fifth
century if you look a hundred years
later you know Visigothic Spain or North
Africa these were now flourishing
kingdoms in a very real sense like
prosperity had returned somewhat
political stability was better these
Germanic tribes ended up being the sort
of nobility noble class right and
because they ended up because they still
had this sort of high level of trust at
least with each other unlike the Roman
elites which had low trust with each
other and had gone into this spiral of
betrayal and constant sabotage they
governed better Ron talks a lot about
how killing and power struggles have
been going on for really long periods of
time and how he thinks that would you
still agree Ron that they're gonna exist
for the rest of time yes the dark
villain that'll they'll always be a dark
villain that's just what we signed up
for too
it helps us become better people do you
agree somewhat do you think there will
always be a dark villain and
I'm not sure it might be that I do think
it's there's a very simple human drive
to you know let's have an enemy and then
we can pin our problems on the enemy and
we can organize against the enemy but I
think at one point we're going to have
to transcend that yeah it's a question
of when I definitely agree that I don't
expect any immediate you know I don't
expect immediate let's say a salvation
from this state of humanity but I do
think like a gradual growth to more and
more coordination and knowledge as I
agree right
but what we have to understand is that
you know political progress is very
fragile peace is fragile
yes war comes easily yes and secondly
the institutions that transfer knowledge
are fragile right Confucius's success is
that that he does have a student that
carries a decision if Confucius failed
at that yes there would be no you know
correct
there will be no golden age of the Han
and Chinese civilization would be very
different from what we know today
Wow and in the you know knowledge the
Roman context you know one can talk
about the negatives or positives of
Christianity I think a positive is the
fact that they have these monasteries
that they set up in the fourth and fifth
centuries who are these resource
autonomous communities people basically
leave urban life like today we tend to
forget that you know when people first
came up with the idea of a monastery it
was like to leave Rome to leave
Alexandria to leave these large cities
that were at that point no longer such
nice places to live and go into these
essentially intentional communities and
in these intentional communities they
copied religious texts but also as a
side effect they ended up copying a
bunch of other texts that would be lost
fifth sixth seventh eighth ninth century
it's not economical to produce books
it's not economical to produce books
about poetry or classical sorry or
classical Greek philosophy but because
the Christians think some Greek
philosophy is relevant for Christianity
the monasteries end up copying this even
though it's uh NECA nama chol so those
are I think successful institutions in
the sense that they successfully
transfer and preserve the body the
material body of knowledge
that is such a crucial highlight because
we were talking about this a little bit
beforehand but the preservation of
knowledge and something that you've
studied as well is really well
illustrated by the canoe example which
we've talked about on the show so many
times now the civilization makes the
canoe someone knows how to make it then
then the civilization goes and continues
to fish with the canoe fish fish fish
for generations the canoe breaks nobody
knows how to make the canoe anymore it's
so important to know how to make the
canoe and to invent and innovate on the
canoe over and over again make it better
over time and that's one aspect like
you're describing here of knowledge
being retained and iterated on over time
and really really honing in on that as a
crucial part of life to hone in on and
do now there's another point that I want
to address on the way to this question
that I want to that I want to ask and it
is that within the within these the
these structures that are being that
we're kind of highlighting and talking
about about civilization you have a you
have a we have a propensity to highlight
these these key moments these these
crucial takeaways from these periods of
time and they seem to be they seem to be
kind of something that we should have
right out into our our highlight book of
civilization something that maybe a
child should go and explore like what
it's like to be Confucius these are like
I'm there almost peeks into history I
like to I like to call it a peek into
history as in its uh we've talked about
this on the show with Rodney loca that
were almost we're almost taking an Intel
aport akancha sness into that moment in
time 2500 years ago into that moment in
time 1500 years ago and and by doing
that teleportation of your consciousness
into what it would be like to really be
in someone's feet body brain at that
time of when Confucius was doing his
work or when the room was having all
these internal conflicts
by peeking our our mind into that period
of history and trying to live what it
would be like to be there that I think
expands our minds to that dimension of
thought that's really crucial for the
takeaway I think I think that's problem
that's quite right we're you know humans
are what we are we learn partially when
we learn from other people through
essentially empathy through emulation
you know monkey see monkey do we can
learn many things through imitation but
ultimately like the imitation has to be
appropriate to our time and it has to be
this independent spark of creativity
where we apply a principle that we learn
from a concrete example to a different
concrete example it's one thing to say
well you know knowledge was preserved in
the monasteries of the Roman Empire or
Confucius successfully selected and
employed his students he taught his
students so that they could be advisors
of ministers of state even if he himself
could never be a minister of state at
least not very good one at least he
couldn't win at the local politics of it
even if he could win at knowledge these
are two concrete examples but what's the
generalization the generalization
derived from this is that society needs
islands and reserves of knowledge a
society loses the knowledge to build a
canoe an example you brought up because
there's a possibly no local economic
incentive for anyone to figure out or
learn how to build a canoe you have to
support yourself while you're pursuing
knowledge okay economic incentive to
have knowledge or even an island if
people are not incentivized to produce
knowledge but they have a secured
existence that allows them to pursue
knowledge some of them will pursue
knowledge for personal reasons so you do
need the economic niche and the social
niches like well if everyone is saying
that this kind of knowledge is pointless
why are you going into canoe making the
canoe is fine the canoe will be fine for
the next hundred years that does not
encourage young minds especially young
bright minds to go and figure out how to
make the canoe how to innovate on the
canoe and then if they did innovate on
the canoe like was this worth their time
maybe maybe not
example would be AI minging cars
autonomous cars or AI making cell phones
and computers and then all of a sudden
humans don't know how to make them after
a couple of generations I think this is
more similar than you might think
right if I go touch again on this
example that I went very deeply into
earlier the Romans didn't know how to
train good soldiers anymore yeah Romans
imagine the Roman Empire didn't know how
to make good soldiers anymore now in the
ideal world maybe we don't need soldiers
right after you know the dark villain
has been banished there's no need for an
enemy but for a state in that period and
even today you need to know how to make
soldiers right and this is a training
regiment these are highly organized
institutions like the Legion you know a
Roman legion would march 3040 miles and
then they would build a fort every day
you just build a fort to sleep in yeah
yeah think of the logistics challenges
of that right yeah
and let's just hone in how advanced this
is most Roman soldiers died in combat
four centuries after this most soldiers
died of disease in other words the
Romans have such good sanitation most of
their soldiers make it to the
battlefield alive they don't you know
die of dysentery or whatever this has
only reached in the later 18th century
so there's this institutional knowledge
of how to do sanitation logistics
training how to manufacture weapons at
scale cheaply like iron swords all of
these can exist and be implemented in
people who don't know how to build such
systems remember when we talked about
bureaucracies earlier about how there
exist things that are written for people
and things that are written for rules
it's possible to have a bureaucracy a
system where everyone knows their local
rules and they know how to write the
right document so the document makes its
way up the office to the manager but no
one knows how the whole thing works yeah
no one individual in it and if no one
individual or small group of people can
get together and say you know this do we
at the DMV are we like really on board
with doing what we're doing or are we
just following the rules and kind of
don't care and don't know like the tax
code as well I know yeah and I do pick
the example of the DMV because it's like
the want some
everyone's experienced right everyone's
experienced a machine a bureaucratic
machine that treats you away another
human being never would write another
human being can be vindictive or petty
but you can reason with them you can
talk to them you can relate to them okay
you can't relate to the DMV reason with
the view you can't reason with the DNA
either so imagine if all of society were
just made up of these large unreasonable
machines horrible I think we're pretty
close to that we're getting yeah kind of
okay this is a perfect segue into what I
wanted to get out which was your
analysis of institutions and what we're
just literally talking about the DMV one
right continue analyzing institutions
right now you brought up the Facebook
example how they have this fascinating
right amount of psychometric data
correct and then we they're not
presenting it in some beautiful graphics
that are very relatable for the world to
understand how we think and all this
kind of stuff
so what happen alysus has been and how
can we how can we get better analysis of
institutions so that way we can prosper
better hmm this is an interesting
question I would say that as a society
we have to first come to the idea that
know it's possible to know truth if you
think it's not possible to know truth
then it's going to be very difficult to
sell people on the possibility of
building knowledge it's going to be hard
to produce but the social economic
political and intellectual Nisha's
necessary for people to pursue it no
truth yeah knowing truth is possible we
have to start with that yeah if knowing
truth isn't possible I would argue it's
still better to live a life thinking
knowing truth is possible again with
humility so you don't fall into
dogmatism and for you know the
willingness to let go of what isn't so
in favor of what is right but the key
question is how to slightly rephrase it
how can we have knowledge produce good
effects it's a simple truth that not all
of us are interested in the same things
not all of us are going to be looking at
all of the institutions of
society many more of us should be
looking more at how our civilization
works how the canoe is built why is the
DMV there do we need it could it work
differently but it's an interesting
question as to how to have it so that
decision makers and institution builders
know the landscape understand the
landscape I think it takes a very
special person to either be a leader or
to organize others towards a positive
end it's much easier to to push against
an external enemy it's much harder to
say we are going to solve this problem
like with a with like a certain kind of
calmness the calmness that comes from
knowing that this problem is going to be
solved and others to perceive this and
then believe this person and work with
them right it takes a certain kind of
credibility so I would say that there
have to be positions in society where
people are known to be credible they are
known to have their incentives set up
correctly with the Facebook example the
incentives are not set up correctly
Facebook is you know doing I would argue
probably a decent job of you know being
a social social network I certainly for
sure I certainly use it yeah so they are
using this knowledge for something yes
but this knowledge is locked in this
little socio-economic niche where it's
not in the interest of anyone engineer
from Facebook to be like you know what
I'm going to figure out how social
movements work and then I'm going to go
start a social movement - you know maybe
reform the DMV right yeah that is not
going to happen it doesn't make sense
for any individual in their life to do
it and if they do try to do that they're
going to be both legal barriers because
they're not allowed to use the data that
they've you know discovered the stuff
they learned it's not like Facebook has
a vital interest in you know not using
this knowledge further they just don't
want their competing social networks
making use of it for their and there's a
little our economic and political
incentivization - right reform the DNC
so we sort of need a bootstrapping
process where you begin with some social
knowledge you look at the landscape as a
whole you figure out where this
knowledge can be applied well you apply
it well there
gather more resources share it with more
people and then you continue step after
step after step until you reach the
point where even the largest elements of
society become amenable to like reform
and upgrade and this ideally is a
peaceful process yes it's not a process
where you're seeking for scapegoats or
for enemies it's a process where you're
identifying followers and then figuring
out logistically what has to be done to
get to the next step right you know
maybe what we need is a Roman legion of
you know social investigation and
building instead of going there you know
have the Legion go kill some barbarians
somewhere maybe what you need would be
like someone that spent a long time
thinking about a particular problem that
knowledge being displayed verified
written about and then people who are
very good at organizing very good at
making contacts on the ground in an
organized way coming to somewhere and
just talking to all the individual
humans that make up an institution like
the fact is if all the people who are in
a bureaucratic machine decide together
we're not playing this game anymore then
it's just the game it's just over like
we think of these institutions as
immobile immovable and they often are
but that's because the people within
them have no means to coordinate outside
of the institution itself as soon as
there are alternate means of
coordination this flows very easily
right I
you mentioned the founding fathers
earlier in the conversation mention
America it's very good to remember that
what happened with the Continental
Congress in particular was well 300
thinkers politicians and you know
creators and yes wealthy people elites
gathered together in a Congress in
Philadelphia and they say American
government is going to work like this
from now on and it did there was no one
in the country to stop them it worked
out it was arguably benevolent it was
arguably better than the articles of the
Confederation sir articles of the
Confederation and the American
Constitution is arguably a successful
political experiment at least it was you
know we'll see what happens in the
future this is what a very peaceful so
reform can look like and I prefer I
prefer the Continental Congress to the
Revolutionary War because it's a war
people die if you go yeah and what we
forget today is that it had a very high
social cost something like you know the
10 15 percent of the population were
loyalists which means that they didn't
want to break away from the British
Empire after the Revolution those people
that fled to Canada right even today in
Canada you have people who have a united
Empire
what is it United Empire UE after their
name because their descendant from
basically American refugees right I
think it's good to remember that the
American Revolution also had refugees
there's people who faced political and
economic persecution in the immediate
aftermath then there was a whole
civilization of natives that were
displaced around the manifest destiny as
well I mean you know Native Americans
preferred the British crown to the
American Continental Congress because
the British crown wasn't that interest
in you know expanding the colonies the
Continental Congress was right Andrew
Jackson so on you know Thomas Jefferson
they wanted to expand into native land
but from the perspective just a
self-interested perspective of the
British crown the natives were useful
balance to the colonists I am loving the
analysis that we're going through even
the present moment how and we can foster
really strong economic and political
incentives for people to analyze they do
have back to history a cannon and I
wanna I wanna because we were we're
gonna have to do another session where
we unpack more but let's go to three
thousand 18 because this is let's go to
this timeline and we've done a really
good job at unpacking some of the first
principles of learning and curiosity and
humility and critical thought and then
we do a really good job at kind of
unpacking some of these ways to analyze
realms of time from Confucius to Rome to
today and then all the way let's talk
about some of the futures so hop for
from these from from all these ways
we're talking about like a Khan
to Congress maybe that might be one of
these good ways to progress into the
future rather than killing people so
what are do you think are these
institutions that are currently doing a
good job and not progressing us into the
future how do we build new ones that we
haven't even thought of yet
as we go into the future maybe even just
a couple decades to a couple centuries
onward right right I think that
currently we're facing several big
challenges one of the challenges we're
facing is it's not clear whether the
Industrial Revolution has that much
steam left in it we've all become vastly
wealthier than we were two to three
hundred years ago yeah but economic
growth is on paper and in reality
sluggish in Western countries despite
advances in things like machine learning
arguably also advances in genetics
second challenge our intellectual
institutions are becoming more and more
unmoored and by intellectual board
unmoored like ships without anchor right
they're no longer grounded in good
epistemic Salus they made that you know
at the start it's a really good point
there are so many academic institutions
that don't have a truth anchor or an
epistemic anchor yeah right right like
you I can go into some details of the
problems with a khadeem it has many
problems one basic problem is that you
know publish or perish in the 19th
century sure perish
yes in the 19th century it was
acceptable for a mathematician to spend
years and years and then publish one
very good piece and then continue years
and years of research no publication
publish another very well thought out
piece you can't make an academic career
like this anymore you can't be an
academic for ten years and published two
good papers right so you have to
constantly be producing papers
regardless of whether in reality or
producing new breakthroughs which means
that only a small number of papers as an
actual have actual breakthroughs and
then this imposes a massive search cost
because if you try to learn the
literature I at one point definitely dug
very deeply into you know political
science sociology all of these
literature's and the signal-to-noise
ratio is very bad yes basically have bad
study after
study built to help someone and I don't
begrudge them at all they should
definitely have an economic and social
niche it's just unfortunate that they
have to produce noise in order to keep
their economic and social niche it's
like the the paperwork gets in the way
of the actual research yes right and
it's a totally separate activity and
then the people who excelled at this
system will be the people who excel at
the paperwork not people who excel at
the breakthroughs yes it's an
interesting question whether you know
Einstein Albert Einstein could have been
published in today's peer-review system
peer review for Albert Einstein was he
talked to his smart friends he's smart
his friends he could find it there was a
thing called the Olympus Club in
Switzerland which was just a club of
smart friends of Einstein he talked him
and he showed him his paper and they
talked in depth about his paper and they
say you know what this is pretty good
let's find someone who published this
and then together with his friends found
an editor who based on their good
reputation and their proven track record
of identifying good scientists yes had
the paper published yes that's how real
breakthrough that's a real breakthrough
that's nothing not this not the system
that publisher pay a pair pay payroll
correct that's also causing a lot of
noise the economic structure is
incentivizing it in the wrong way okay
so that's the academic institution side
of thing and then there's obviously news
yeah keep going yeah obviously in news
it used to be the case that there was a
public conversation I mentioned public
intellectuals like who is a public
intellectual a public intellectual is
someone who looks at society identify as
a key you know key issue thinks about
concepts relevant to this issue and then
brings these concepts relevant to that
issue to the public awareness yes it
you're doing right now what we're trying
to do we'll see how receptive society is
you know we at with what drives traffic
is you know is it the newspapers is it
the tweets or is it the ideas there was
a time where there were more ideas
driven arguably ideas never mattered as
much as people pretend they mattered but
they've had heard more than they matter
now on the Renaissance days true and
this is a lot of what we're doing is
trying to rebirth the
public intellectual that's a lot of our
mission if we can get people that want
to talk in public settings on large
stages on large vodcasts in terms of the
analysis of civilization and the
mechanism and the niche of the public
intellectual is one that is people are
interested people are interested in
learning about the world either to
satisfy their curiosity or for practical
action so if you have people that have
identified key problems and concepts and
information relevant to those problems
and then make a career of disseminating
this information that is one way in
which knowledge can be transferred right
if there's a video on YouTube it's
available to everyone right most people
watch it they might be entertained they
might be interested not much happens but
that knowledge is there online available
for someone that might be researching
the topic themselves it's very difficult
you know signal and noise right we
talked about the signal-to-noise ratio
in the academic world online we
obviously face again a signal-to-noise
ratio problem if the very best thinkers
you know of our time are talking with a
loud speaker not everyone might be ready
to listen but some will it's the long
tail like the long tail of the audience
is going to be the most impactful yeah
right and the public conversation which
once existed was more focused on well
they are these people who are thinking
about these big ideas and what do these
ideas mean for society and then there
was a public conversation between them
like you said critique was a vital part
of it right can you imagine two or three
people showing up on stage and then in
the course of a live discussion actually
changing their minds yeah exactly
or maybe crying or being vulnerable or
so you should the love and compassion
these are things that it really is
difficult to drive out of men especially
and I'm I'm trying to do my best to open
that up I can understand this it's a
it's it's it's the case that you know
it's hard to imagine but you know I'm
going to contrast a modern institution
and an old one modern American Congress
19th century British Parliament in 19th
century British
people would change their vote in
Parliament on the basis of speeches yes
so in other words it can you imagine
someone in Congress today just being
swayed by the arguments of the opposing
side rather than by the lobbyists money
that's preferable right or their own
party machinery that's being like no you
have to be loyal to your party and if
the party line is stupid will so much
worse for you you're gonna have to vote
on a stupid thing that's so great to cut
my speeches that are going to have maybe
maybe Congress speeches would be worth
listening to if they were intended to
change minds of the legislators
themselves I love that for that thought
right like can you imagine that a
society everybody tuning in and
listening to the speeches because they
actually do because they had good
content have good content and they're
actually relevant can you instead of it
be for sort of like sound bites or
optimized for like this very shallow
kind of tribal popularity we're
harnessing too much you know today in
American society is too much of our
attention is harnessed by the tribal
instinct we have part two that's gonna
have to happen because this is unpacked
just the beginning and it's been an
amazing time unpacking this with you
thank you Sam well thank you so much it
was a pleasure to be here thank you for
coming on to the show we barely even got
to you know some of them even our simile
simulation questions about asking you
about being alone in the cosmos or being
in simulation we can definitely save
those because we can come back and do
more unpacking on civilization and then
we'll also do some unpacking of these
simulation questions thank you everyone
for tuning in this has been a great
episode on flourishing and the decay of
civilization we really greatly
appreciate you guys viewing liking
subscribing commenting below sharing
this content with other people getting
more people inspired to talk about how
civilization has flourish in the past
how it's decay and how we can move
forward thank you very much for tuning
in
join us on patreon so a huge deal for us
to keep the studio alive to keep us
independent we would greatly appreciate
that huge shout out to Ronda Vargas are
producing partner with the show thank
you very much and we'll catch you guys
very soon thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you